new atheism like to present itself as
this kind of rebellion against the
mainstream but it was you know it was
very much pushing an Open Door religion
religious decline was was already
happening anyway amongst the educated um
all over the Western world I mean it was
partly motivated by sort of fear of
Islam but they didn't it was sort of
impolite to say that and it was
definitely like you know provoked partly
by two um 911 um but actual Christianity
was in such decline it was actually sort
of going with the grain of popular
thought um I think saying that actually
Christianity is good is very much
against the gra